who's under the most pressure for week
five big cat you've got the trivia
question to determine the first pick lay
it on me i do uh there are three
quarterbacks michael who haven't thrown
an interception this year including
russell wilson
who has the record for the most games
played to start a year before throwing
an interception
aaron rodgers
i knew you were going to say that you're
so dumb bernie kosar
1991.
that's an impossible trivia question
because i thought the same thing as you
that's an impossible trivia question
yeah well thanks for looking out for me
because when they give me a really hard
question i say it's too hard make it
easier so uh that's what you should have
done you should have said it's too hard
make it easier yeah no no i had to get
the first pick he gave me an easy
question first i said make it harder all
right my first pick because i'm gonna
dominate this draft and i'm happy i got
the first pick
the most pressure
the winless group the winless quad the
quads of winless coaches who are new
coaches zach taylor
vic fangio
cliff kingsbury and brian flores now
cliff kingsbury and zach taylor
obviously playing each other but the
pressure now mounts when you are a new
coach and of course there you get a
little leeway
but if we get to week six and you
haven't won a football game the
pressure's now on these guys they have
to perform they have to have their teams
get in the win column just to relieve
that pressure a little bit so i'm saying
the winless
rookie head coaches
now see ordinarily i would let this
slide but since you came out vowing to
dominate the draft i need to ask you
who's brian flores playing this weekend
oh mike you fell right into my trap you
are so stupid that was so easy brian
flores is not playing anyone the
dolphins have a bye week but that means
the pressure's more on him than ever
because if vic fangio wins if if uh zach
taylor wins then you have three of those
coaches they you know cliff kingsbury
has a tie vic fangia would have a win
zach taylor would have a win brian
flores would be the lone member of the
winless tiles rookie head coaches so he
has the most pressure because he's the
only one who cannot get a win this week
which actually he couldn't get a win if
the dolphins were playing but he cannot
get a win this week with a bye week so
he's got to sit there and he's got to
root for the chargers and he's got root
for a tie in the cardinals and the
bengals game
okay
uh
all right that's a good pick you you
have to agree you get leeway as a rookie
head coach to a point if you get to week
five week six week seven without a win
there's a lot of questions that could
start to get asked but are any of these
guys i mean let's let's be real here do
you envision any of those four guys
potentially being one and done
it doesn't matter if they're if they're
one and done or not and i would say
actually that
yeah i could see a world where john
elway uh you know irrationally says
we're getting rid of vic fangio um or
even a world where cliff kingsbury i
mean yes it could happen but mike it's
not about the one and done it's about
the next season and when you start the
next season if you have a terrible if
you win two games and the next season
starts and you're slow to start then
then you get the are they going to move
on from him in the middle of the season
are they going to move on on from him
after the second year it's all you know
how this is you need to start building
equity early because as soon as there's
doubts in that building whether it be
from the locker room or all the way up
top as soon as those doubts those those
seeds are planted you're in
trouble all right i'll accept that one
now i have been picking on kirk cousins
a lot in recent days for good reason i'm
not going to put him on this list today
but i am going to go one level higher
actually two levels higher if we
consider kevin stefanski is his
immediate supervisor i'm going to mike
zimmer the coach of the vikings because
i think zimmer has so little patience
for the kinds of things he should be
paying attention to with his football
team that he's allowed problems to
fester without nipping them in the bud
the adam thielen comments from after the
game on sunday bill belichick would have
been all over any player who said the
things thielen said and it would have
been theo and apologizing to cousins not
cousins apologizing to thielen and then
you had the cousin's apology to thielen
and then you had stefan diggs the no
call no show on wednesday where they
listed him as not practicing because it
wasn't injury related no it's not injury
related he stayed home and didn't show
up for work and then when he came
thursday they let him talk to the media
and he made it even worse look they've
got festering problems in minnesota and
mike zimmer as best i can tell is the
only person in position to clunk heads
together and get this stuff right and
now the pressure is on him to do it
because he failed to do it before we all
knew about it i agree with you here mike
and if as we're sitting here right now
october 4th the vikings are the worst
team in the nfc north wouldn't you say i
mean they are well they're in fourth
place
and they're the least com i have the
least confidence in them turning it
around because the the the lions have
looked good the packers have aaron
rodgers and the bears at least have a
otherworldly defense that they can
always rely on what do the vikings do
better than anyone else is run the
football but they can't run the football
half the time so i yeah you're right
mike this is a big game for mike zimmer
especially as heavy favorites on the
road uh okay my second pick is going to
be the atlanta falcons now i've had a
long and storied history with the
atlanta falcons i actually have bet my
pinky i will cut off my pinky if they
win the super bowl this year i am done
with the atlanta falcons but
they're under a lot of pressure because
they have not shown up at all this
season they are
so bad when it comes to getting in the
red zone and putting points on the board
they are so poorly coached and dan quinn
is firmly on the hot seat i think this
is the guy who you're looking for
there's always one or two guys who gets
fired mid-season or towards the end of
the season before it all ends up and
they you know the team tries to get a
jump on their new hire i think dan quinn
is the guy you got to circle if this
continues to go poorly and the falcons
end up one and five one and six
i thought we don't talk about another
man's job
we don't but i'm just saying if
i agree with you on that one all right
let me move on uh and and this is
something that i've been saying
throughout the week big cap but since
you don't listen to the show you're not
aware of this the steelers have not yet
faced lamar jackson as a starting
quarterback
lamar jackson is going to be under
tremendous physical pressure on sunday
because i think the steelers are going
to dust off the rg3 game plan from 2012
when robert griffin iii was taking the
nfl by storm ryan clark former steelers
safety has since explained what their
plan was that day to beat the hell out
of rg3
every chance they could get there was a
play when he lined up wide as a receiver
they destroyed him they hit him every
opportunity they could get to break his
will to break his spirit and they're
going to do that to lamar jackson that's
been the big concern that we've had
about jackson especially when he runs
the ball he's going to take too many
hits and it's going to affect him at
some point and the steelers are going to
test that out they're going to come at
him old school style they're going to
hit him relentlessly will he hold up to
it he's under pressure
i i do listen to the show and i'll tell
you why i listen to the show because i
heard you say this take this exact take
and you said it's going to be like the
steel curtain which i don't know why
your brain is stuck in 40 years ago but
it is let me move on okay let me pull
mike floyd let me move on my third under
pressure the nfl schedule makers
ten games at one o'clock
two games at four o'clock we need to
make enough noise that this never
happens again this should never ever
ever happen we should have an even
amount of games the sunday feels like
it's completely lopsided we're going to
get to the four o'clock after an
unbelievable witching hour with 10 games
at one o'clock and we're going to be
stuck with you know the chargers in the
broncos and the packers the cowboys and
there will be times when both games will
be
you know in commercial and we'll be
sitting there not watching any football
fix it fix it nfl schedule makers i
don't ask a lot i'm asking for this
don't do this anymore i think there's a
couple other times in the season where
it's scheduled for this change it now
because people are going to start making
noise the nfl schedule makers are under
pressure this weekend see i don't have a
problem with it well first of all what
pressure they under the schedule's
already set the pressure i'm gonna
complain that's the pressure all right
but but if there's only two games and
one of them is like the game of the
afternoon then i'd rather not be
distracted by other games i'd rather go
all in on cowboys packers i don't have a
problem with it as long as one of the
two games is expected to be a great game
you sound like someone who doesn't
gamble
no you're correct i don't um
and and look i i i like
i like being able to watch one game at a
time and the more games that are on at
one o'clock it's harder to keep up with
everything but you know what if there's
more games on at one o'clock chances are
you're gonna have that moment where
there's a great finish here then the
great finish there there's a great
finish here and those are memorable and
those are great red zones if you're a
red zone person those are great
afternoons and the more games that are
crammed into that window the greater
chance we're going to have one of those
10-minute windows where so much happens
and seasons turn on a dime and that may
happen on on sunday afternoon all right
last one for me um hmm i can go a bunch
of different ways here let me go
with the jets doctors
because sam darnold is pushing hard to
play this weekend the jets want him on
the field and somebody's got to be the
grown-up in the room and i know darnold
has said he doesn't want to die on the
field which i think is you know a fairly
important objective to have whenever you
play football but the doctors are going
to have to be willing to say we're not
letting this guy play and sometimes you
have to stand up to the coaching staff
you have to stand up to gm you have to
stand up to the owner and it's a it's a
delicate relationship because
if as team doctors you all of a sudden
start giving advice that defies the
wishes of the organization
they're eventually going to find other
doctors who will tell them what they
want to hear so this is going to be a
real test
will they let sam darnold play will they
give in to the pressure that will be on
them to let sam darnold play we're gonna
find that out at some point before one
o'clock eastern on sunday big cat
yeah that's a good call and i love the
uh sam donald might be able to play or
his spleen might be so big that he dies
just kind of throwing that out there one
or the other those fields yeah one of
the there's no middle ground no middle
ground it's one of the other it's flip a
coin flip a coin we'll see what happens
all right uh we'll take a quick break
and we will wrap up this friday edition
of pft live once you get a chance to
digest that i have destroyed big cat in
this draft with mike zimmer lamar
jackson and the jets doctors he has the
winless coaches including the one who
doesn't play this weekend atlanta
falcons and the nfl schedule makers
we'll be back with more right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports